[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est le tour d'horizon
de l'actualité locale et régionale tout
de suite les titres de ce mardi à 16
avril une grande partie du début
d'édition sera bien sûr consacré à l'
incendie de notre dame de paris les
flammes ont ravagé la charpente du site
et sa mythique flèche et les pompiers
des yvelines ont été envoyés sur place
à suivre les réactions des élus
politiques du département mais aussi des
yvelinois qui contribuent déjà
financièrement à la reconstruction de
l'édifice
l'actualité du jour c'est aussi
l'ouverture du salon des maires
d'ile-de-france trois jours d'échangés
de rencontres avec les partenaires des
villes à la porte de la villette à paris
est l'occasion de connaître les attentes
des maires sur la réforme des
collectivités territoriales et sur la
décentralisation
et puis c'était hier au lycée et van
gogh d'aubergenville une journaliste
un journaliste syrien a rencontré des
élèves de 1ère rendez vous dans le cadre
de renvoyer spéciale une opération mise
en place par la maison des journalistes
et nous parlerons également tout à
l'heure des huitièmes rencontres
kreactive qui se tiennent ce jeudi au
ski cube c'est à guyancourt
c'est un symbole de la france dans le
monde dévasté par le feu à la cathédrale
notre dame de paris a été ravagé par un
violent incendie qui s'est déclaré hier
en toute fin d'après-midi la charpente
de l'édifice a été en grande partie
détruite la célèbre flèche de notre dame
elle s'est effondrée la structure dans
sa globalité serait fort heureusement
sauvé la piste accidentelle est pour le
moment privilégiée par les enquêteurs
est le site qui a été en grande partie
sauvegardée grâce au travail sans
relâche des pompiers cette nuit vous
voyez sur ces images tournées par les
pompiers de paris l'un d'entre eux a été
légèrement blessé tout comme deux
policiers en renfort pour cette
opération les pompiers des yvelines 35
hommes ont été envoyés à paris est
notamment du groupe d'intervention en
milieu périlleux trois officiers chef de
groupe également du matériel mobilisés
et quatre fourgons incendie deux bras
élévateur de 46 mètres de haut que vous
voyez à l'image venant des casernes de
versailles à de magnanville elle est
plus eaux d'ile-de-france des
équipements qui ont eu une action
déterminante dans la sauvegarde du
beffroi nord de notre dame de paris
et forcément de nombreuses réactions
suite à cet incendie les premières que
nous avons collecté ces têtes hier soir
elles sont de valérie pécresse et de
gérard larcher
les deux y vino était à bois d'arcy pour
le meeting de françois xavier bellamy
dont nous reparlerons plus tard dans
cette édition
interview enregistrée juste avant leur
départ pour paris écoutez je suis
dévastée par les images absolument
dramatique nous voyons cette charpente
cette flèche qui s'effondre notre dame
de paris notre monument de coeur notre
monument français qui est en proie aux
flammes
alors je pars immédiatement à paris avec
gérard larcher pour me rendre au chevet
de du diocèse au chevet des français au
chevet des pompiers aussi qu'ils sont
mobilisés pour éviter que ce drame ne
tourne au drame national
et je crois que malheureusement il est
déjà trop tard et je crois que nous
allons devoir faire preuve d'une immense
solidarité pour réparer ce qui est en
train de se faire notre dame de paris si
un symbole symbole xxème siècle là qu'on
chante le tdm après la libération de
paris symbole dans une semaine symbole
pour les chrétiens qu'est la semaine
sainte et l'eau républicain que je suis
ne peut qu'avoir une vraie pensée pour
celles et ceux qui s'apprêtaient à
célébrer la semaine sainte dans notre
dame de paris et au delà tous à notre
dame
c'est plus qu'un symbole c'est une
référence
c'est quelque part sur cette île paris
ancré sur la scène est ancré dans son
histoire et son patrimoine et notre dame
de paris un symbole pour la france mais
aussi pour le monde entier réagi de son
côté jean michel fourgous le président
de saint quentin en yvelines était au
micro de nicolas landry de patrick
jacques de dixmude ce matin depuis le
salon des maires d'ile-de-france en
franchise infranchissable c'est sûr que
un des plus beaux sites mondiaux je
crois que
ce qu'on peut voir c'est d'abord
l'immensité
de la réaction c'était une émotion
planétaire dirait on voit qu'il ya une
très forte émotion des français une très
forte une sorte de réveil de la prise de
conscience de leurs racines de leur
histoire de leur système de valeurs
ça oui c'est impressionnant n'a d'autre
réaction à vous proposer parmi les élus
politiques yvelinois dans un communiqué
pierre bédier s'exprime le président du
conseil départemental des yvelines salue
le travail des pompiers qui a permis de
conserver la structure de la cathédrale
l'homme la firme le département
contribuera à la reconstruction de notre
dame qui est inscrit au patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité sur les réseaux
sociaux plusieurs réactions également
une peine immense pour joséphine coleman
bergé vice présidente à la culture au
conseil départemental des yvelines est
la mère de plaisir appelle à la mise en
place de relais pour des dons à dans sa
ville quelle douleur de voir notre dame
de paris brûlé s'est exprimée la députée
de la 10e circonscription des yvelines
aurore bergé qui a tenu à apporter son
soutien aux pompiers engagés et même
soutien du côté de la députée de la 5e
circonscription du département il ya une
brawn peavey un sentiment général
qu'elle partage immense tristesse devant
les images aux effroyables de notre dame
fin de citation notre dame de paris en
partie détruite et c'est aussi toute la
communauté catholique qui est touché à
quelques jours de la célébration de la
fête de pâques qui en pleine semaine
sainte
écoutez ses propos de l'évêque
auxiliaire du diocèse de versailles
recueillis par michael et demi d'euros
beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup de
solidarité aussi beaucoup d'émotion
parce que notre dame
évidemment c'est notre patrimoine à tous
et que on se sent tous touché au coeur
par ce qui s'est passé cette nuit à
paris et puis beaucoup de solidarité
parce que pour nous catholiques on entre
dans la semaine où il ya les plus
grandes célébrations religieuses autour
de pâques et savoir que les catholiques
de paris ne pourront pas faire ces
célébrations dans leur cathédrale c'est
vraiment un déchirement
on pense à eux ce soir durant la messe
chrismale à saint louis à versailles on
sera vraiment de tout coeur avec les
parisiens pour lesquels d'ailleurs les
cloches de saint louis ont déjà sonné
cette nuit monseigneur aumônier a fait
sonner les cloches en solidarité avec
paris
et le diocèse de versailles qui doit
rencontrer celui de parier pour voir de
quelle manière il peut aider à la
reconstruction de notre dame est toutes
les cathédrales de france d'ailleurs
seront demain sonneront demain leurs
cloches à partir de 18h50 heure du début
de l'incendié en solidarité avec
l'édifice de paris la dernière réaction
à vous proposer celle des yvelinois
croisé ce matin au centre commercial sud
canal à montigny le bretonneux interrogé
par manon varaldo et calypso vanier j'ai
été touché fin j'ai l'impression qu'on
touche et paris ça faisait un peu mal au
coeur et ému j'ai été surpris sachant
que je connais bien le coin là bas j'y
vais souvent voir coeur ma famille c'est
quelque chose de tragique mais de pas
complètement négatif je pense enfin
puisqu'on peut pas revenir en arrière au
temps en faire quelque chose de positif
et faire en sorte que grâce à ça
permette aux gens de se remettre
ensemble ses tripes c'est un beau
monument donc ça fait toujours mal au
coeur de voir autant d'années de
l'histoire et puis deux
c'est quelque chose d'assez beau de
partir en fumée comme ça d'un coup
j'étais assez choqué sur tout le monde
la chute du du de la flèche
j'espère qu'on aura tous les fonds
nécessaires pour réaliser le plus
rapidement possible la préservation et
de remettre tout en état
comme c'était auparavant pour que le
monde entier les visiteurs puissent
revenir un jour même dans cette belle
cathédrale et la solidarité a été tout
de suite au rendez vous suite à l'
incendie de notre dame de paris pour
reconstruire la partie détruite de la
cathédrale plusieurs fortunes françaises
ont déjà annoncé des participation
conséquente à plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros
la fondation du patrimoine qui est en
charge de la sauvegarde et de la
valorisation des monuments français a
lancé une grande collecte nationale et
les français sont déjà au rendez vous
près de 4 millions d'euros à l'heure où
je vous parle on t ont été collectées en
quelques heures vous pouvez donner sur
le site fondation tirait patrimoine
point org
à noter également des aides des
collectivités territoriales celle par
exemple de la région ile de france qui
va débloquer 10 millions d'euros en
urgence pour les premiers travaux du
site annonces de valérie pécresse la
présidente de la région
aides et subventions enfin de la part de
certaines villes saint germain en laye
va apporter 20000 euros annonce de la
municipalité sur twitter un chêne de la
forêt de saint-germain-en-laye sera
également offert pour la reconstruction
de la charte de la charpente et 20000
euros aussi pour la cathédrale le maire
de versailles françois de mazières
elle proposera à son prochain conseil
municipal
et j'ajoute enfin qu'à un rassemblement
citoyen se tiendra ce jeudi à partir de
18 heures devant l'hôtel de ville de
poissy
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire ce soir
sur l' incendie est de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris et sur les
différentes réactions et dans le
département des yvelines
trois jours consacrés aux élus des
communes franciliennes le salon à des
maires d'ile-de-france 2019 a ouvert ses
portes ce mardi au pari seven center de
la ville est un événement organisé par
l'association des maires d'île de france
dans un contexte particulier pour
lesquels les collectivités territoriales
alors que le président de la république
doit faire des annonces suite au grand
débat national nicolas landry et patrick
jacques de dixmude un contexte
particulier pour l'ouverture du salon
des maires d'île de france 2010 9
difficultés quotidiennes des communes
etc
crise sociale des gis les jeunes le
président de la république doit faire
des annonces suite au grand débat
national et les maires franciliens ont
des attentes
il ya manifestement des réformes à faire
peut pas rester avec un mille feuille
territorial qui ont fait que côté aux
citoyens et dont les citoyens ne veulent
plus par qui ne se reconnaissent plus on
nous annonce vraiment une anticipation
de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation beaucoup plus tôt que ce
qui était prévu puisque normalement
c'était pour la fin du mandat
sauf qu'on ne sait pas trop comment
financièrement ceux ci va être compensé
au niveau des villes mais je crois que
vraiment faut changer de logiciel pour
le pilotage de la france quel que soit
les mandats c'est vrai du mandat numéro
si demain on veut des gens encore plus
compétents avec stéphane beaudet maire d
evry courcouronnes nouvelle la commune
nouvelle et président de l'association
des maires d'île de france
alors dans quel état d'esprit sont les
maires franciliens d'abord ils sont
toujours constructif et combatifs ils
sont pas abattus
ils n'ont pas encore abandonné le navire
jusque là pour une grande majorité
d'entre eux non on est au moment d'abord
du bilan delà de ce mandat puisque c'est
le dernier salon avant la fin du mandat
on est aussi au bilan du grand débat et
de l' affaire dite des gilet jaune avec
des cahiers de doléances que montré une
profonde défiance du peuple à l'endroit
dans les gares notamment du pouvoir
central
mais une forte demande en même temps de
renforcement du pouvoir local et donc du
coup après avoir été vilipendé et
traiter de clientéliste on voit que les
maires reviennent au coeur du débat et
redevienne une nécessité dès lors qu'il
s'agit de retisser le lien social avec
les habitants donc on est dans cet état
d'esprit constructif et puis pour la
construction et la réinvention du modèle
communal de demain la décentralisation
elle a commencé dans les années 80
un premier acte ensuite un second tact
dans au début des années 2000 tout ça
ces moments s'adaptera oui oui je crois
que c'est le moment de l'acte iii se
pose toujours la question évidemment du
millefeuille institutionnel se pose
toujours la question même si on enlevait
la clause de compétence générale aux
départements et aux régions du fait que
beaucoup de collectivités font la même
chose et dépensent de l'argent
inutilement qu'on sait plus qui fait
quoi et qui fait voilà et puis de toute
façon se pose quand même la question de
la relation de confiance et démocratique
avec les habitants et ça c'est les
maires qu'ils ont faim le seul élu
apprécié des français ça reste le maire
voilà c'est le seul qui est encore qui
est encore reconnue si on ne renforce
pas celui là si on ne renforce pas la
collectivité locale alors on ne
réformera jamais ce pays présente aussi
à l'ouverture de ce salon la ministre de
la cohésion des territoires jacqueline
gourault et la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse chacune
ont défendu leur modèle de réforme de la
décentralisation une fois que ces
décentralisée il faut que les
collectivités territoriales au fonds
prennent leurs responsabilités c'est le
mot du président de la république
jusqu'au bout des compétences parce que
souvent on est encore dans un système où
l'état à un bout des compétences les
collectivités à notre bout alors il faut
certainement clarifier cela
moi je crois qu'il faut que le président
de la république comprenne que les
territoires et les élus et bien sont au
plus près des préoccupations des
français et qu'il faut décentraliser on
en a assez de la technostructure qui
doublonnent qui complexifie qui empêche
les interdits des échanges et des
rencontres avec leurs partenaires privés
et publics les maires partagent aussi
leurs expériences ce salon le dernier de
leur mandat avant les élections
municipales de 2020 et le scrutin des
européennes lui approche élections à
suivre le 26 mai prochain avec des
candidats qui bat campagne dans les
yvelines c'est le cas de françois xavier
bellamy tête de liste les républicains
le philosophe et maire adjoint de
versailles tenait un meeting hier mardi
au domaine de la tramblais à bois d'arcy
250 personnes environ étaient présentes
pour la soirée quelque peu modifié en
raison de l' incendie de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris valérie pécresse et
gérard larcher son parti en tout début
de réunion présence dans la salle des
élus de la droite yvelinoise
parlementaires et conseillers régionaux
et notamment pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
écoutez françois xavier bellamy c'est
une joie d'être ici ce soir dans les
yvelines d'être ici pour pouvoir
partager ce moment de réflexion sur
l'europe avec gérard larcher avec
valérie pécresse avec beaucoup de
grandes figures de notre famille
politique dans notre département nous
pouvoir échanger avec tous les militants
et de partager avec eux notre projet
pour l'ordre un journaliste syrien à la
rencontre d'élèves de première c'était
hier au lycée van gogh d'aubergenville
cette intervention s'inscrivait dans le
cadre de renvois
et spécial opération organisée par la
maison des journalistes cette
association vient en aide aux
journalistes étrangers en exil aurait
dire on va assister à cet échange
zaher al zaher à 23 ans photo
journaliste syrien il est arrivé en
france il ya un an jour pour jour devant
deux classes de première du lycée van
gogh à aubergenville et il est venu
témoigner de son parcours mais aussi de
la difficulté d'exercer son métier en
syrie il n'y a pas d'organisme officiel
il ya les forces fidèles au régime et la
société civile
elle est complètement livrée à elle même
et du coup c'est la marche et
journaliste engagé depuis le début de la
guerre
alsa air est intervenue dans le cadre de
l'opération renvoyer spécial un
dispositif organisé par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale et la maison des
journalistes
cette association unique au monde
accueille et accompagne des
professionnels de l'information
contraints de fuir leur pays
la situation de la presse en syrie un
moment très dangereuse donc les
journalistes les activistes comme ça
elles qui ont documenté ce qui s'est
passé un céline dans leur pays
donc dû frapper un moment donné le mans
la porte à la maison des journalistes
pour demander un accueil et un
accompagnement
objectif de l'opération renvoyer
spéciale à sensibiliser les plus jeunes
à la liberté d'expression et aux valeurs
citoyennes
quand il parle qu'il n'y avait pas d'eau
pas de nourriture on pose la question
comment ils ont fait pour survivre
jusqu'à maintenant c'était touchant
c'est intéressant et savoir ce qu'il a
vécu lui-même vraiment c'est mieux que
par simplement des médias la télé pour
pouvoir mieux communiquer zaher apprend
le français et l'anglais et rêve de
continuer son métier de journaliste dans
son pays natal
je veux finir mes études et je veux voir
la syrie se libérer je ne veux plus voir
de guerre je veux que les gens puissent
revenir habiter dans leur pays
on reconstruire ce qui a été détruit et
tout refaire à nouveau depuis 2002 plus
de 400 journalistes ont été pris en
charge par la maison des journalistes
un mode économie avec cet événement la
8e édition des rencontres
kreactive se tiennent ce jeudi au ski
cube c'est à aiguille en cours et ce
sont des réunions qui sont organisés des
événements sont organisés par
l'association créactive bonsoir claire
vigneron d'être la secrétaire de cette
association créée active alors avant de
présenter l'événement représentons cette
association qui a fêté cette année ses
15 ans est une association qui regroupe
des femmes entrepreneurs oui tout à fait
ça a été créé au départ en fait pour
accompagner les femmes créateurs ou
porteurs de projets d'entreprises qui
sont aussi les bonnes compétences comme
les hommes qui sont confrontés à des
problèmes que ne connaissent pas les
hommes
donc l'idée c'était ça c'est vraiment à
travers des rencontres régulières et des
ateliers de donner des outils dans la
bienveillance pour aider ces femmes et
pourquoi une association justement de
famille d'entrepreneurs vous vous en
parliez des femmes d'entrepreneurs qui
rencontrent parfois des difficultés
qu'ils rencontrent souvent des
difficultés
oui déjà l'isolément quand
on veut construire sa propre activité en
est seul et une une des raisons des
façons de pouvoir rompre l'isolément
c'est de rejoindre cette association
pour rencontrer d'autres entrepreneurs
qui ont de l'expertisé de l'expérience
et qui vont pouvoir apporter des outils
pour pour aider ces femmes qui se posent
des questions et qu'il n'y arrive pas
tout seul mais bien combien d'adhérentes
aujourd'hui à créac'h tir 150 en cas
d'accord et vous rencontrer toutes les
semaines alors on organise quatre heures
rendez-vous dans le mois un café qui a
lieu une fois par mois où on va débattre
autour d'une thématique et pour donner
aussi pareil des outils à nos collègues
entrepreneurs
on va organiser des ateliers le soir où
des conférences par décret active ou par
des intervenants extérieurs autour de
sujets qui préoccupent tous les porteurs
de projets et tous les créateurs
d'entreprises et ces femmes est le
problème de différents secteurs
d'activité s'est tassée différencier
c'est complètement différencier on a pas
mal de femmes qui sont autour dans le
secteur du bien-être mais il y en a
aussi dans le marketing dans la
communication dans la formation vraiment
tous les métiers sont représentés des
compétences différentes et vous disiez
de nombreux rendez vous organisé par
l'association dont le prochain c'est ce
jeudi aux cubes à guyancourt les 8e
édition
la 8e édition pardon des rencontres
créactive c'est quoi l'objectif de ce
rendez vous l'objectif c'est d'organiser
des rencontres pour que les porteurs de
projets ou les créateurs d'entreprise
puissent rencontrer des experts des gens
qui ont une expérience et on va leur
permettre d'assister à des ateliers à
des conférences de débattre de poser des
questions et de pouvoir en une
après-midi une bonne demi-journée avoir
un pôle de compétences à leur
disposition pour avancer dans leurs
projets
et pouvoir avoir des outils concrets
alors alors proposé et vous c'est à dire
que ça s'adresse pas que vos adhérents
de créatif c'est plus large c'est pour
un plus large public
ah oui oui c'est pour tous les porteurs
de projets les créateurs les créateurs
d'entreprises jeunes ou moins jeunes
il ya beaucoup de choses qui changent je
pense par exemple à la formation
aujourd'hui il ya de nouvelles
réglementations qui sont mis en vigueur
par le gouvernement et qui permettent
aux créateurs d'entreprises et aux
aux entrepreneurs d'accéder à des
formations qu'elle n'avait pas forcément
droit il ya quelques années encore donc
ils pourront avoir ici des informations
par exemple
alors chaque année il ya un thème cette
année c'est l'entrepreneur face à ses
choix pourquoi choisir ce thème
expliquez-nous un petit peu ce thème
parce que l'entrepreneur est toujours
face à une feuille blanche et se pose
toujours la question dans quelle
direction il doit aller quel choix il
doit faire pour bien gérer son
entreprise pour choisir les outils dont
il aura besoin pour à faire avancer
faire croître son entreprise avoir de
bons résultats
quelle personne il devra rencontrer pour
l'aider aussi dans ses démarches
donc la vie de l'entrepreneur c'est un
casse tête chinois et et qui est tous
les jours confrontés à des
problématiques de choix et c'est un
événement qui se déroulera de 12h à 20h
le programme alors dans les grandes
lignes
quels sont les temps forts de cet
après-midi du coût de cette grande
après-midi il ya six ateliers qui seront
organisés donc 1 à 2 par heure autour de
la vitalité par exemple choisir votre
choix de la vitalité son lieu de travail
le choix de la formation le choix de de
gérer le stress parce que c'est une
grande problématique aussi aujourd'hui
le choix du digital pour mon entreprise
et il y aura aussi des tables rondes
donc le but c'est qu'il y ait des
questions réponses et que ce soit
interactif
les visiteurs ne viennent pas uniquement
pour écouter mais aussi pour interagir
pour qu'il y ait un échange pour y
participer il faut s'inscrire on avance
oui c'est une journée qui est gratuite à
c'est un événement qui est gratuit mais
qui nécessitent d'être inscrits parce
que on a aussi une problématique de
place donc il ya beaucoup de monde qui
viennent à cet événement on peut
rencontrer les experts donc il faut
absolument s'inscrire en amont sur le
site décret active justement qui s'est
affichée qui s'affiche actuellement on
peut vous souhaiter koala pour ces
huitièmes rencontres et bien de belles
rencontres
une belle dynamique des experts qui sont
là pour les pour les entrepreneurs pour
les créateurs d'entreprises donc
n'hésitez pas à venir nous rejoindre à
nous rencontrer rencontrer tous ces
experts qui sont la disposition et cette
huitième rencontre
kreactive se déroule ce jeudi jeudi 18
avril au ski cuba guyancourt essai de
12h à 20h toutes les informations sur le
site internet de l'association merci à
claire vigneron merci secrétaire de
cette association a créé active du sport
à présent c'était une première à
mantes-la-jolie la ville a accueilli le
mondial du golf pendant trois jours plus
de 100 exposants sont venus tout le
week-end pour présenter leurs produits
golfique et les visiteurs ont pu les
tester retour avec mickaël millero et
patrick jacques de dixmude dix mille
amateurs de golf se sont rendus ce week
end à mantes-la-jolie la ville a
accueilli du 12 au 14 avril un grand
salon sur la petite balle blanche
une grande première pour la commune et
le département des yvelines qui compte
26 golf de 18 trous sur son territoire
c'est un rendez vous de passionnés c'est
un salon communautaire autour de la
passion golfique c'est à dire que le but
de l'événement c'est d'immerger les
passionnés dans leur secteur de passion
avec toutes les composantes de la
culture golfique avec du club avec du
chaussant de la balle
des éléments techniques comme été les
maîtres ou les montres connectés qui
permet de géolocaliser connaître la
distance jusqu'au drapeau
au total une centaine d'exposants
étaient présents pendant les trois jours
du salon pour séduire encore plus les
golfeurs les organisateurs ont également
mis en place un practice de 120 mètres
en plein air pour tester le matériel
dans des conditions réelles
c'est un plus parce que les joueurs
veulent essayer les clubs en plein air
ils veulent voir la balle volée ils
veulent voir les performances avec
chaque marque donc c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment très très important rythme là
ça sauve pas mal donc on peut se rendre
vraiment compte des trajectoires des
balles et
comment dire des fsi un signe en effet
s'est vraiment amplifié par part
justement le vent il deuxième édition
est déjà programmée pour l'année
prochaine à la mi avril l'objectif sera
d'attirer encore plus de golfeurs et
notamment des débutants et pour la fin
de ce journal c'est mélanie poker qui
m'a rejoint un plateau bonsoir ça au
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines on vous emmène à travers
l'histoire grâce aux objets pour sa
nouvelle exposition le site par des
objets de notre temps et c'est votre
coup de coeur culture de la semaine mais
là n'est pas moins de 90 objets sont
rassemblés au coeur du musée au sein de
son exposition temporaire
une plongée au coeur du 20e siècle
l'exposition débute plutôt dans les
années 30 mais il ya surtout un gros
focus dans les années 60-70 savez
grégory cette époque où les objets
pullulent les trente glorieuses c'est
l'arrivée massive de la publicité
création d'objets nouveau mais aussi de
nouveaux métiers durant ces années le
designer imagine toutes sortes d'objets
au fond nous original voire improbables
et surtout c'est une explosion de
couleurs et c'est une exposition qui est
pensé de façon thématique
oui alors elles sont au nombre de quatre
ces thématiques il y à la cuisine
l'hygiène des nouvelles technologies qui
concerne principalement le salon vous
pourrez notamment voir à l'évolution des
postes de télévision et la 4e thématique
c'est le confort là il sera plutôt
question des fauteuils mme et des sièges
et en cette époque on consomme beaucoup
mélanie c'est une exposition qui peut
faire réfléchir
et oui pourquoi pas l'exposition apporte
aussi un regard critique sur la société
de consommation à travers un regard
plutôt originale des chansons populaires
de l'époque interprété entre autres par
gilbert bécaud et serge gainsbourg alors
l'exposition débute dès demain mercredi
17 avril et vous avez jusqu'au 27
juillet pour découvrir tous ces objets
et peut-être vous rendre compte que dans
votre denis grenier se cache une pépite
comme vous en aurez au musée de la ville
merci mélanie pour cette chronique et
vous prendrez ma place dans quelques
instants à la présentation du 7-8
culture un retour notamment sur l'
incendie de notre dame de paris et les
réactions sur le monde culturel du monde
culturel yvelinois qui seront à suivre
dans ce zoo dans votre émission est la
fin du set 8 journal c'est à retrouver
également sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 je vous
retrouve dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition en direct et ce sera à partir de
leur belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]